well asking what what's the one thing
you can do is a bit of a dumb question
it's always a bit more asking do you
want a hard to you are along the answer
is you want both they've had to focus on
one thing I think the world community
has to concentrate on not overreacting
to issues so for instance and not
reacting to the stock exchange for by
over protection to recognize and what
has helped the world community and to
continue with it so to continue with a
critical long-term issues so we'll focus
on the long-term rather overreacting to
short-term and the long-term issues
remain hidden on poverty they remain
climate change and they remain getting
the best out of globalization that's
what I would say keep focusing on the
wrong term and going out too much too
short thank you